vous le savez la loi 3DS relative à la
différenciation des centralisation et
des concentrations a été adoptée par le
Parlement il y a plus d'un an ce texte
prévoyait la suppression du plafonnement
des sessions de terrain aux communes de
Guyane cette disposition était de nature
à faciliter la mise en œuvre de l'accord
de Guyane du 21 avril 2017 l'état
c'était engagé à cédé 250 000 hectares
de terrain à la collectivité de Guyane
et aux communes pouvez-vous me dire où
en sont les décrets d'application
deuxième question bon c'est sur un peu
sur la SAFER mais il faut en parler
quand même on peut panier l'importance
d'une structure telle que la SAFER sur
mon territoire vous venez donc parler
Monsieur Martin pourtant près de deux
ans après la création de la SAFER du
Guyane la structure ne dispose toujours
pas d'agrément ni de droits de
préemption or ces outils vous le savez
sont primordiaux pour permettre à la
structure de mener à bien ses missions
doit-on paralyser le fonctionnement
d'une telle structure pour un problème
de personnes et une dernière question
j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller sur le
terrain avec l'exécuté monsieur damessin
nous avons rencontré les jeunes
agriculteurs qui souffrent après une
succession de suicides d'agriculteur et
ben voilà je sais qu'il doit remettre un
rapport il m'avait dit que c'était vers
fin février début mars nous sommes en
avril donc je voulais juste savoir où ça
en était monsieur dame a remis son
rapport il y a une semaine et on a la
semaine prochaine une séance de
présentation du rapport de Monsieur
Olivier damaisin au cabinet du ministère
de l'Agriculture je l'ai lu il y a
plusieurs recommandations on a des
sujets
sur lesquels aujourd'hui j'ai pas de
réponse je pense l'exemple des pistes
agricoles on connaît que les pistes
agricoles sont pas entretenus en
particulier ces pistes qui ont été
faites par l'ONF
et
l'OMF quand elle a fini son exploitation
elle arrête d'entretenir la piste
moi je ne sais pas aujourd'hui à qui
appartiennent ces pistes elles
appartiennent à qui c'est parce que
l'ONF les a faites qu'elle en est
propriétaire
je crains qu'elles appartiennent aux
communes mais j'en suis pas sûr j'en
suis pas sûr et que les communes
aujourd'hui de tout simplement n'est pas
les moyens
d'entretenir ces pistes et que donc
s'ils ont des pluies étant scalés en
Guyane les agriculteurs qui se sont
installés le long de ces pistes après
quand le NF s'en va la piste devient
extrêmement dégradée et on a les
difficultés qu'on connaît en Guyane
c'est un des éléments qui est mis en
avant et sur lequel il faut qu'on
travaille avec des des spécialistes du
droit qui me disent à qui appartient ces
pistes et ce qu'on peut faire est-ce
qu'on peut mobiliser du fait Ader pour
entretenir ces pistes par exemple c'est
une possibilité
faudrait que leur statut soit précisé en
tout cas le rapport est prévu la semaine
prochaine sûr le transfert des 250 000
hectares en toute honnêteté je vais vous
dire je ne sais pas où en sont les
décrets c'est pas un sujet que j'ai
suivi c'est pas un sujet de ma
compétence et je suis d'accord je
je déplore avec vous ce transfert n'est
pas été fait à la date d'aujourd'hui
mais je veux pas sur la question précise
où en sont les décrets franchement j'en
sais rien faut que je me renseigne voilà
je suis désolé de pas pouvoir vous faire
une meilleure réponse
que celle-là et sur la SAFER bien sûr
que la situation actuelle n'est pas du
tout satisfaisante je suis d'accord
vous étiez venu avec Monsieur patient
à au ministère pour tenter de défendre
j'ai reçu Monsieur monsieur monsieur
servil qui a tenu le même discours que
vous comment ça se fait que
pour que la SAFER n'est pas le droit de
prévention pendant tout le temps on
discute on palabre et bien la
spéculation foncière continue est-ce que
ça est-ce que c'est satisfaisant bah non
bien sûr que c'est pas satisfaisant
c'est c'est quoi le problème on a
procédure actuelle qui dit d'abord il
faut agréer le président ensuite il faut
un dossier
d'agrément de la SAFER et une fois que
la SAFER est agréée automatiquement sans
qu'il y ait besoin de prendre aucun
texte elle est elle a le droit de
préemption
c'est la procédure actuelle bon on a une
difficulté
avec le
qui sont des difficultés sur lesquelles
je veux pas parler ici parce que c'est
on n'a pas le droit de parler de la
situation individuelle des personnes
mais je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous que c'est une situation actuelle
n'est pas satisfaisante ça je suis
d'accord et qu'il faut absolument
avancer pour
qu'on aboutisse voilà